daniel morin merci beaucoup d'être là
vraiment ce soir vous êtes faire de jean
christophe morin
oui victime présumée dorna le landais
alors nous sommes avec jean christophe
morin il a disparu en 2011 aujourd'hui
sa famille on est persuadé nordahl le
landais est impliqué dans ce tram ce
dossier fait partie de la quarantaine de
dossiers
voilà de god cas est étudié par une
cellule spécialisée de la gendarmerie
pour déterminer l'implication ou non de
nordahl le landais en 2011 dans quelles
circonstances a disparu votre fille jean
christophe jean christophe est parti
avec des camarades avec l âge 22 ans
d'accord il est parti donc à une à une
fête aux fortes amiez une teuf votre
compte mon église
et puis bah là bas et c'est c'était la
fête pour tout le monde donc ils se sont
plus ou moins séparés et quand ils ont
voulu repartir ils ont un peu cherché
l'ont pas trouvée après bon ben c'est
tous entre potes
il y en a qui sont rentrés puis lui bas
au bout de quatre jours
ma fille adeline s'est dit mais temps on
n'a pas nouvelle il est où là et à
partir de ce moment-là bon on n'a jamais
plus une nouvelle vie a disparu alors au
départ dans la fête voulait plus jamais
revu ah bah non
quelles sont les premières pistes des
enquêteurs au départ ils disent quoi
qu'il était parti de sa propre volonté
elle a une voix dit jean-christophe ses
enquêtes à la fin a été prise au
sérieuse à dix mètres plus loin que
comme le caporal qu'ils ont tout de
suite tout déclenché ça n en est loin là
il n'avait jamais cru à la thèse de
l'accident
alors moi je pensais qu'il était parti
en vérité j'étais en déni tout au début
je voulais revenir à un moment oui je
pensais qu'ils étaient peut-être parti
dans un autre pays ailleurs pourquoi pas
après tout ce qui m'étonnait c'est qu'au
bout de huit mois il est pas téléphoner
alors qu'on n'était pas fâché rien du
tout alors ce qui se passe c'est qu'un
an plus tard
écoutez bien cette histoire folle un à
un autre va disparaître pendant le même
festival
ahmed hamadou en 2012 un an après et
c'est ce qui va vous mettre sur la piste
d'un tueur en série
c'est à dire que l'on s'est dit
attention et en font deux c'est un peu
bizarre moi j'ai appelé les
donc la maman tout ça tout au début bon
et c'était tout au début juste un peu
froid parce que pourquoi une téléphone
tactile à l'arrière donc et puis bon bah
petit à petit quand même on a on s'est
dirigé vers la gendarmerie qui nous a
dit que c'était un concours de
circonstances paris d'accord voilà
concours de circonstances et puis on a
fait des années partie justement cette
année là c'est aberrant parce que
pendant qu'à mettre disparaît mois avec
des amis on avait pris une tente on
avait fait trois mille tracts et on a
mis des tracts sur toutes les voitures
on en a distribué à tous les gamins là
bas et si ça se trouve comme je disais
ça fait pas très rigolo mais la somme on
a même mis un trek sur la bagnole à la
sueur des voix lors vous enquêtez vous
trouvez une vidéo du festival en 2012 où
vous pensez à percevoir quelqu'un
ressemblant à nordahl le landais
regarder
[Musique]
alors vous au lit pour santos penser que
c'est normal le landais s'inquiétait à
cette fête je sais pas c'est pas vous
avez enquêter là dessus oui et non ça
c'est pas ma vidéo par contre j'ai
jamais vu une aussi et on voit bien sa
main on la voit en bas là encore il ya
une bague carré ouais et quand on le
voit ce gala en tout cas c'est vrai
c'est quoi ça mc voilà sur notre photo
ouais il à la mc carey au mondo harris
et 90 c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est quand même aberrant et puis moi
j'ai faim je fais un appel à témoins
même encore aujourd'hui le monsieur qui
est là si c'est pas le landais mais qui
téléphone qu'il espérait que dit
monsieur ou alors quelqu'un qui le
connaît ce monsieur parce que c'est pas
lui mais non c'est pas lui vous l'avez
déjà fait ça et personne n'a alors
personne n'a appelé pour une bonne nuit
et raison c'est que le mec qui est là il
est en taule en compte pour vous c'est
normal le landais c'est quand même fou
parce que c'est vrai qu'ils soient au
festival lasser c'est incroyable que ce
soit vous qui fait l'anc est quand même
daniel c'est quand même incroyable ça
excusez moi en argile il n'y a qu'en
une plainte a été reçue pour enlèvement
séquestration avant rire d'ailleurs
qu'ils ont considéré qu'il était parti
pas eu d' enquête vient et c'est
l'obstination de la famille les
documents de la famille qui ont fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya sans doute une
proximité
normal le landais sans vous monsieur y
aurait rien votre sang n'aura plus
jamais entendu parler c'est surtout
adeline qui a fait tous mûri ben nous on
était un peu derrière et là on prend la
relève parce que l'on peu plus long mais
gaouaoui incroyable le dossier avaient
été refermées monsieur morin je crois
que le dossier avait été refermé en 2013
voilà absolument absolument aller et
après on a appris un peu la trajectoire
de votre fils je sais pas si vous le
saviez mais enfin être les années de
galère à paris puis l'a été vivre chez
votre chef chez adeline c'est à dire
qu'il était à saint girons avec nous bon
quand même les les copains qu'il avait
aux alentours c'est un peu chaud oui ça
c'est sans que adeline a bien voulu
prendre ce statut magnifique sous sa
coupe
là-bas s'allonge bon on peut pas dire
que c'est vraiment très bien réussi mais
une voiture je crois près du lac
voilà il était dans une île est assez
marginal mais ça c'est pas arriver
n'importe comment aussi il était dans un
il avait un petit travail dans un
restaurant et
bon ben juste qui se passe en ce moment
on vire les premiers arrêts les derniers
arrivés donc il a été il est partie du
boulot c'est parce qu'il n'y avait pas
assez de travail pour tout le monde n'a
pas été par il n'est pas parti parce
qu'il travaillait mal pourrissante or
aujourd'hui il ya le le procès nordahl
le landais qui démarre c'est quoi le
profil psychologique de dalles le
landais vous qui avez beaucoup travaillé
sur lui c'est un fou furieux mais il
sait ce qu'il fait d'accord moi j'ai
parlé pendant deux heures hier avec son
ex copine en date
d'accord on lui a montré une vidéo du
soir de la disparition du caporal noyer
on le voit surgir à la boîte de nuit
ils savaient exactement précisément où
étaient toutes les caméras il était en
survêt avec une capuche sur la tête
il tournait la tête dès qu'une caméra
était braquée sur lui il savait très
bien ce qu'il faisait le mahdi il
ressemblait à un lion un prédateur en
quête de sa proie d'accord donc moi ça
fait ça fait trois mois maintenant que
j'enquête jour et nuit sur lui j'ai
découvert pas mal de choses sinon ils
peuvent qu'inquiéter pour le meutre le
maire de la petite maëlys il aurait
continué pour c'est son parcours
criminel parce que c'est vrai que c'est
ça qui vous parlais tout à l'heure de
l'ex de normal le landais une semaine
avant la disparition de la petite maelys
elle lui révèle qu'elle a voulu porter
plainte pour menaces de mort d'accord
elle arrivée au commissariat la police a
refusé de prendre sa plainte prétextant
que nordahl est un mec bien
ouais ça c'est factuel ça je vous le
révèle ça c'est pas sorti c'est
incroyable c'est ce que c'est ce qui est
sorti de mon entretien de deux heures
hier avec l'ex copine en date de nordahl
cod des choses comme ça il y en a plein
malheureusement les dossiers l'aquadôme
à tous vous diront négateurs nous
rejoindre là aujourd'hui on a à peu près
certain qu'il impliquait dans plus de
deux meurtres
voilà donc deux c'est sûr plus de
données sur temps quatre gars affaire de
moeurs c'est sûr après il ya combien d
affaires ça je peux pas vous dire par
contre ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il n'était pas seul ah oui ah oui ah
oui c'est à dire il a peiné dans un
environnement propice
tout ce qui est survenu quand ils
avaient des complices ouais il
fréquentait une club de boxe dans
laquelle il ya des pédophile notoire
dont des gens qui ont été condamnés dont
un qui a été condamné pour quatre
agressions sur mineur et qui a bénéficié
d'un simple bracelet et il y avait aussi
d'autres gens qui l'a notre site qui
violait sa fille ait enfanté saphique
accouché sous x et ça des exemples comme
ça je vais dévoiler très bientôt pour le
deuxième
02 02 l'envers d un ferrer les exemples
comme ça il y en a à la pelle des
témoignages j'en ai à la pelle saccage
beaucoup de crasse toussaint mais c'est
fou normal c'était un soldat
ouais c reçoit des ordres bien sûr
qu'ils les donnent exactement
vous pensez qu'il avait il été qu'il
était téléguidé c'est un point ouais
c'est un soldat exactement comme pour
fournir et d'ailleurs fournir et ancien
coach à qui on a appris à tuer qu'on
relâche dans la nature
voilà qui servit de nordahl le landais
pour lanvin le landais à la base c'est
un dealer connu pour sa dans son bled
mais à cocaïne
en plus c'est un vendeur ils vous disent
quoi ses proches à nordahl de lourdes et
je peux pas faut faire très attention à
ce que je dis parce que sinon j'aime
réveiller avec une plainte demain mais
sa famille n'est pas très nette dans
l'histoire parce que la police le sait
ça j'espère en tout cas c'est l'apogée
beaucoup de choses que je m'apprête à
voile a révélé un des plus grand tueur
en série français pour vous vous savez
il ya des cas de destruction de preuves
aussi dans cette affaire est un gros
coup de coeur bonjour pensez que la
ferme nordahl le landais lé pire plus
important de ces pas l'histoire d'un
homme a dans l'histoire de tout un
groupuscule non non non c'est pas du
tout vous dites que si rien sa pensée
qui est des gens de l'armée qui sont
impliquées dont je pense oui mais il a
été la réponse est oui dans ces
incroyables
il ya un ami du 3è du 13e bca hautement
comme le caporal noyer donc est-ce que
ça c'était pas par exemple un règlement
de comptes a bien sûr le caporal noyer
mais ça des exemples comme ça il y en a
à la pelle mais moi j'aimerais insister
sur la destruction de preuves si la
charte des gendarmes c'est un des
exemples comme ça j'en ai plus que le
shaq de jean-christophe qu'on a
retrouvés au fort tamié on a appris il
ya quelques temps et qu' il avait été
détruit parce qu'au bout d'un certain
temps les preuves il est garde pas alors
on a à l'heure actuelle on a des les
nouvelles informations qui disent qu
avec l'adn on va de mieux en mieux on
trouve de mieux en mieux
il aurait peut-être pu réétudier le
sache essayez trouvait justement là
petites gouttelettes qui traîne toujours
là où il faut pas ben le nom ça risque
pas là maintenant c'est fini ça qui les
ont même pas demandé si on voulait le
récupérer
rappelez vous de la gendarmerie qui a
été incendiée et concernant tous les
scellés sur la firme à l'hélice coup sûr
ça a été revendiquée par un soi-disant
opus ce groupuscule anarchiste fait midi
sans plus et tout le monde a pris ça
pour argent comptant mais
croyable